and don't you waste it
Jennifer Lopez's daughter can say JLo
straight up slate at the Super Bowl
performing the halftime show alongside
Shakira but it's her 11 year old
daughter Emmy with her exhale arch
Anthony that has us screaming yeah
that's a me hitting the Superbowl stage
during her mom set at the big game
[Applause]
who else is shook she is 11 guys 11
anyway Emmy showed off her vocal chops
singing her mom's song let's get loud
and Bruce Springsteen's born in the USA
[Applause]
[Music]
and she looked cute AF in an adorable
white dress and boots totally holding
her own next to her famous mom I know
Jennifer is excited our family's excited
and the internet was feeling it
one fan tweeted quote baby Emmy
absolutely killing it look at this
little star while another wrote J Lo's
daughter Emmy coming through with the
real vocals Emmys famous dad also hit up
Twitter to send a shout-out to his
little girl and her bomb performance he
wrote quote Emmy daddy is so proud of
you you are my heart and I am forever
yours and sobbing of course this isn't
the first time we've heard Emmy hit the
high notes
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in 2019 JLo shared this video of her and
Emmys singing on stage together in Los
Angeles
[Applause]
she captioned the clip quote I can't
take it
hashtag Emmy hashtag limitless hashtag
proud mama and that that's Emmy singing
Alicia Keys I mean full-body chills
she's got her daddy's voice oh she's got
both she's amazing
jennifer gushed over her little girl's
natural talent when et caught up with
her in 2019
I mean Emmy always could say I remember
when she was in the crib when she was a
baby she used to be humming like really
humming to herself and Dan and and Marc
would say she's singing he's like it
feels good to her it feels good to her
soul and to her like her body he's gone
he was like that and I was like I think
you think she's singing he goes yeah
yeah yeah and he was right and she's
always just since she was little she
could always sing but Jayla played coy
leading up to her halftime performance
when asked about the rumors that she
might be incorporating her kids Amy and
her twin brother Maximilian in the show
I don't want to give away too many of
what we're gonna do in the performance I
know you guys don't have a lot of
questions about that but the truth is
it's I think when we finished the first
run-through
you know Shakira looked at me she was
like that was amazing and I was like no
you were amazing and I think it's we it
was very she was like it's different
what we do yeah amazing is an
understatement of course you can count
on et to bring you all the latest on JLo
so make sure to keep it locked right
here until next time I'm Hallie Stevens
bye for now
[Music]